hello rejection Greg Alba here and John
Humphrey over here I got one hour of
sleep I'm clearly taking care of my
health very well after developing a
ringing hear infection I've been at
YouTube space all day Asus videos
probably going up in the morning of an
MBA YouTube space all-day filming a
pilot presentation actually with a
Lauren Francesca from I want my Lauren
want my Lauren yeah it was really fun
YouTube space is like an hour away from
here so I had to get there really early
pretty late but it was a total blast
supposed to go up on YouTube the first
one so yes we gonna see me I have like a
couple eggs a little tiny bit but it's
fun while I was there my brother is
involved in the project too and he got a
message for about this new Star Wars
trilogy oh boy Brian Johnson is set to
develop a new Star Wars trilogy
Johnsonville developed a new trilogy
with longtime collaborator Ram Bergman
and plant stand rot to write and direct
the first installment of the trilogy
asked what this trilogy will entail
details are scarce in shepherding this
new trilogy which is separate from the
episodic Skywalker saga Johnson will
introduce new characters from a corner
of the galaxy the Star Wars lore has
never before explored that sounds really
cool there's pros and cons that I can
see happening to this this seems like it
could be a good jumping-off point kind
of how like fantastic piece was done
where they got the director of the last
few Harry Potter films which were
amazing Rian Johnson there's been no
like stipulation or terrible reports
though for going on the last Jedi other
than the untimely passing Carrie
Fisher's death but there was nothing
really about like oh there's creative
differences happening they're doing a
bunch of last-minute reshoots yeah you
know it's been a smooth process and and
what doesn't seem to have thrown there
100% they released a featurette just
about how great how great Rian Johnson
is and I don't know if they like now I'm
wondering did they do that feature red
because they have Rian Johnson Gunners
directing new ones that we got to get
people the love and trust in we
announced the news or is he just that
great of a director that this was a
recent development where they were like
yo dude we love what you're doing can
you write and direct this new trilogy or
at least the first installment helped
start it get it
on a path that he will ultimately
Shepherd which could be awesome or this
could be a joss whedon situation that's
the other concern because ryan johnson i
like that he does original films yeah
and I like that he does stuff that is a
bit smaller and yeah unique then perhaps
the stars yes but at the same time I
mean that's not to say Star Wars isn't
unique it's still a franchise is what
he's saying where several films deep
we're talking about going several films
great yeah and everything wants to be
stopped just like his own original
pieces that he were like brick or looper
you know just original pieces they
wanted to stick to and there's there's
something about Rian Johnson where at
least thus far he seems like he's got
the skill and finesse and the judgment
to where this sounds like a great idea
for all intents and purposes yes I mean
a skilled and and assured filmmaker for
sure so it's not like JJ Abrams you know
where I'm like all right like I'm
actually interested in this I wrestle at
pros and cons I really mean that because
I have no idea how this direction will
go the fact that this is not going to be
a Skywalker centric based a trilogy is
also really exciting to me because I
don't know him just doing a solo
spin-off actually sounds weirder than
him setting up a new trilogy for some
reason and this could be a chance for
him to truly invent something in the
Star Wars world while he's being
inventive obviously with the last Jedi
he's still continuing something that was
already set up as opposed to censoring
something in the Star Wars universe make
it enticing and interesting and unique
enough where you want to see sequels to
that specific spin-off yeah the Star
Wars world super awesome to me and I
love that it doesn't seem like it's
gonna be heavily reliant on connecting
to on stuff other characters Star Wars
franchise II yeah I like that idea
exploring parts of the Star Wars
universe we haven't seen yet and stuff
like that that you wonder what it's
gonna look like you know cuz especially
with so many spin-offs coming out and a
new trilogy in the word it seems like
there's gonna be a whole lot of Star
Wars in the future and that makes me
kind of conflicted because part of
what's special about these things is
that they're not just accessible to us
at all times there's not a new
installment constantly and now it looks
like there's gonna be well so it's on
those movies to be extra gray
you know to justify keeping this train
rolling for the next 10 years you know
like they want to well think about this
for a second they're actually developing
a live-action TV show now have you heard
about this I saw the headline it's gonna
be on their new streaming service it's
been creating the and that was actually
my first thought that I had he just said
I was listening to Collider movie talk
recently movie and one of the recent
ones Clark wolf was on there and she was
talking about why the Star Wars
franchise felt so special is because we
don't get a billion a year yeah exactly
and even though we're getting more Star
Wars than we've had in a long time it's
still just one movie a year it's not
like three Marvel films a year or two DC
movies a year one Star Wars movie so it
still keeps it special are they gonna do
that with the spin-off is this year's
Star Wars movie whatever you're gonna be
han Solo and then next year we'll get
episode 9 or is it yeah then I imagine
after episode 9 then we'll start this
new trilogy and then maybe continue this
but no this will officially be the Star
Wars see you you know you could argue
that they're spin-offs though within the
same one but when you're going to a
totally separate story outside of
anything linked to the Skywalker story
I'm sure there'll be some type of
linkage but you know what I'm saying
it's anal I haven't really read much
about the Star Wars TV show no details
are available at the series on this
point there was a time in my life where
I did want a Star Wars live-action TV
show there was time I live for that
sounded like a really cool thing
nowadays though I doubt it well ok the
Inhumans like Inhumans for Marvel is a
show that's like this should have just
been a movie then the club would have
been way better especially like blasted
on IMAX to throw this on a streaming
service I mean like how much are they
really gonna throw down because I feel
like for Star Wars you would need the
CGI you would need that all up to par
yeah that would need to be a super yes
show because there's so much legacy and
mythology and so many effects yeah in
the DNA of this and Disney doesn't throw
essentially a crap ton of money for damn
good CGI and
they're Disney produced TV shows now
this would be a brand-new thing where
it's like this is Disney's streaming
service so they might I just think that
for for Star Wars you're gonna need some
pretty cool CGI I like no matter the
story no matter how grounded it is
you're gonna need it yeah exact wraps
and makeups and animatronic and it also
kind of ruins the feeling just a tad bit
the war like I'm totally like once it
watches yeah I'm gonna check it out that
sounds I have to see what it's always
live-action TV show it's a great content
is great content no matter what but the
thing is if it's again I know we've been
talking about this point a lot this year
but you know it is Star Wars it is
arguably the most beloved franchise of
all time so it's a good highest grossing
franchises of all time right behind the
Pokemon franchise there's thirteen
billion dollar bills the Star Wars show
I feel like there's something cool that
could be done with that but I feel like
it it has to bring it in yes to be great
because the problem is now Star Wars is
becoming more and more frequent and
common and accessible and the only way
to keep that really working is by making
sure you have a dynamite product on your
hands it can't be okay can't be alien
covenant you know I might be interested
in it if it has no connection at all to
the Skywalker franchise or this new
trilogy set as well otherwise I'm gonna
go oh
Disney is just flat-out turning star
wars into the MCU right now yeah and I
got your other movies your cinematic
universe and you got your TV shows that
it's like of course I expect the Star
Wars TV show to be connected in some
degree it's the same universe in this
galaxy but I don't want it to be like
yeah this is all tied into movies I've
seen you know yeah well I would I would
hope that with the Star Wars television
show they'll open up and start exploring
some different themes or some different
you know allegorical tales yet if like
that borrow a bit of the intellect from
Star Trek or something like that you
know and make the series some yes
special less about giant spectacle which
I don't think I'll like Star Wars is is
you know as big as it is because it's
only about spectacle this isn't
transformers or fast and furious or
something you know this is something
with much deeper thought and maybe the
show could take the time to reel
explore that yeah and that's what also
gets me excited about Rian Johnson
because he's really into that kind of
thing yeah so if I'm setting up a new
trilogy and a new show yeah
so Rian Johnson's new Joss Whedon so
this is just only about like Chui trying
to kill a fly yeah Millennium Falcon
just can't do it
Chewbacca and we need to know it's all
about how we met Han Solo all right guys
well let's take you to you you're
beautiful bastards listen to Phillip
DeFranco hear hear about that louis c.k
stuff hi so are you guys excited for the
Star Wars trilogy they're just new one
by Rian Johnson what are your thoughts
on it my friends and how do you feel
about a live-action Star Wars TV show if
you say anything negative about it
you're just not a Star Wars hater it's
it's plain simple that's all you are
subscribe to the reel rejects please
click that notification bell you can
follow John Humphrey and I on social
media and please check out our patreon
become a patron object today
people do it could be worth your time
might be worth mine could be worth God's